so today's topic Bruno Mars who
apparently is guilty of a cultural
appropriation but I want to hear
unbiased opinion about from someone on a
very cultural I want to hear if he dies
I'm baking a cake red velvet
[Music]
why is your youtube name sensei I see
matzah all right you [ __ ] my soup ah my
name is my soup means that looks a love
in Japanese right and how much do you
know about Japanese culture well like I
said I know it means I love you so okay
so don't you think that year may be
culturally appropriate from Japanese
culture you laughing laughs you know
waters of culturally appropriate things
from black people you can't then then
your subclone appropriate things from
Japanese culture we never did that and
you guys are bringing up Michael Jackson
people have to campaign to get Michael
Jackson's videos MTV yeah in that same
time period right number one me
personally like I don't even think that
Michael Jackson now in this day and age
will be able to get to the point then
you go back so the industry worked
actively to keep Michael Jackson off the
airwaves but you feel like she would
have more difficulty today where they
would love to have him on the airwaves
mmm
but hey listen this coming from the girl
would bake a [ __ ] birthday cake Bruno
Mars died so you know this shit's funny
why that is because people have realized
that they prefer their black music and
their black culture from a non black
well Michael Jackson lost his popularity
as he became more white in fact Michael
Jackson is one of the only people who
became white and had less privilege of
life back
Batz it's not because you're screaming
facts or their actual facts knock knock
who's there
fat [ __ ] who back door back Toback
artist in the same way that Michael
Jackson was an original artist in the
same way that Prince was an original
artist where Bruno Mars does is he takes
preexisting work and he just completely
word-for-word recreates it extrapolated
you talk about sampling yeah it's called
hip-hop [ __ ] I don't know where you
been on top of to pot songs or samples
from rising seventies and sixties songs
that I'm in love with this is getting
dumber and dumber you read and I get it
black people were upset we're upset
because a lot of white people are doing
things that black people historically
done getting way further with less
talent let's go and that's upsetting but
you're picking the wrong example he is
racially ambiguous he is not black at
all
parole board's my biggest Porto Rican
polynesia the cultural appropriation the
way it works it just means to borrow
elements from another culture so it's
not inherently good or it's not hear me
back
they're just taking these from other
cultures any time you cook a dish for
something else you're culturally
appropriate and technically speaking
fine wherever it becomes negative
somebody opened up an Ethiopian
restaurant and I said it was raw food
from Russia I would be [ __ ] annoying
I get that aspect though okay we want to
do that best fight but I want someone
right now you know takes an aspect of
Ethiopian culture goes to on to win a
war chef and then constantly krytus all
of his inspirations constantly credits
his time in Ethiopia the time you spent
working there as a sous chef and all
that stuff then yeah I'm gonna respect
the [ __ ] out of him regardless of what
race he is because I'm fine with it
every time you hear an interview with
Bruno Mars he always he credit he credit
you tell me yo I got it from there
this is my creation he's the karaoke
singer he's a wedding singer he's the
person you hire to do Michael Jackson
and Prince covers yet Bruno Mars has an
out of the year Grammy and Prince never
won an album Wow they're saying because
he benefits from his racial ambiguity
that's why he's doing this stuff and so
it's what he used to do that stuff and
prisons not racially and whatever else
ambiguous you know
you don't know where princes from if you
look at even though this gender my
[ __ ] mad androgynous listen you don't
know where he's from here's the thing
you definitely write about historically
great black you know musicians and
artists being shunned by award shows
definitely true but I don't do it Bruno
Mars experience I just shows our
evolution as artists you're seeing a
whole bunch of new people winning awards
for the first time Kobe Bryant just won
the first animation award for a black
person ever right whose team Dave
Chappelle get enemies all these
different people get Grammys and things
like that and so as a result were just
seeing these barriers being broken down
where we knew who he was we were singing
his songs before we knew who Bruno Mars
was you notice a like he he wrote and
produced [ __ ] you by CeeLo green he did
billionaire hit like he did all of this
music that we don't even know he was a
part of that go back go back back Toback
fast
that's arguments right there I think
Bruno Mars is an example of progress I
think more and more black people are
starting to win all these awards
everywhere we're seeing in every facet
of the entertainment industry and this
idea that dark skin is now being
ostracized way more than ever before I
think it's completely opposite that's my
take on this now I got a funeral to go
to so I got a big cake piece this night
should we send her a cake making red
velvet
[Laughter]